thanks to notion for sponsoring this
video get your free personal account
at the link in the description hi my
name is dr simon clark i am an
atmospheric scientist turned youtuber
who spent the best part of 10 years
studying the earth's atmosphere and
climate
and then changed to making youtube
videos i also happen to be a fan of bad
movies and i recently learned that
geostorm is available on uk netflix
i've never seen it but this is so up my
alley i thought i'd give it a watch
the first time in this video and
basically react to and discuss some of
the science or black thereof that we see
in it everyone was warned
but no one listened we lost entire
cities
the east river swallowed lower manhattan
a heat wave killed two million people in
madrid in just one day
okay we're not a minute and a half into
this movie
oh okay so let's dive right into this so
the geostorm
is about the deployment of
geoengineering to counteract the effects
of global warming
and what they're depicting in this
opening scene is a single year
in which absolutely every conceivable
natural disaster
hits and we anticipate that as the
climate warms which it has been for
the past several decades uh that
extreme weather is going to become more
common and likely more extreme
depending on the kind of weather like
for example hurricanes or droughts
um we don't know whether that means just
more intense or if it means more
frequent or
both something that is important to
stress though is that
an apocalypse scenario in a single year
is extremely unlikely the uh severity
of the impacts that are being depicted
here like two million people dying in
madrid in a single day
making it look like literally seen out
of the walking dead
why are there so many fires come to
think of it that is extremely unlikely
to happen
climate change happens in slow
increments it's going to be
the slight shifting of spring and or
winter
over or ever so slightly more frequent
occurrence of hurricanes or heat waves
it's not going to be a single year where
everything just goes
now we're in the apocalypse and to think
like that isn't a terribly useful way to
think about the problem because it
certainly kind of engenders an idea of
helplessness i should stress that
anthropogenic climate change
will have significant effects similar to
what's being depicted here but not
so uh short and sharp not over the
course of a single year you're going to
see this many disasters just dialed up
to 11.
facing our own extinction it became
clear
that no single nation could solve this
problem alone the world came together as
one
and we fought back i think if this video
may just be the intro at this rate
okay i'm just gonna let me just let me
let's unpick that human race is not
going to go extinct
as a result of climate change in the
course of a single year
what may happen is over the course of a
century human civilization as we know it
may collapse humans are still going to
be around we're pretty tough
we fought back so this idea of the world
fighting back is a really interesting
psychological point
so take for example the famous picture
of earth taken from the apollo program
this was the blue marble it's i think
the most reproduced picture of all time
and when it first came out there was
this
idea that it was going to engender like
a huge wave of environmentalism it's
like how fragile we are look at how
perilous this blue planet is and yes it
did do that but what it also did was
basically instilled this idea
that humanity was above the planet
the humanity was on top of and it kind
of led this to this idea of
what some people call the god species
that humans can uh
make and remake the earth and that is us
against the earth
it is this idea that we are somehow
separate from everything that goes on
and when you see stuff like we fought
back against the planet
what we're really doing is fighting
ourselves because we
are part of this hugely interconnected
system
and the earth is just responding to what
we are doing to it
what we are doing to it is the problem
so we are fighting ourselves
the idea that we are fighting the earth
is just
quite an is an interesting psychological
point i think it's also quite an
unhelpful way of looking at it because
the earth is not the problem
we are the problem scientists from 17
countries
led by the us and china work tirelessly
in blender apparently so therein lies
one of the major issues when it comes to
geoengineering
saying that it's a coalition of 17
countries it's led by us and china
the problem is that with any kind of
international collaboration
there is only one dial when it comes to
um traditional geoengineering obviously
this is
uh a more sci-fi version traditional geo
engineering is what's
normally solar radiation management so
basically dimming the sun
um and there is one dial to that there
is the dial of how many aerosols you
want to put into the atmosphere how much
sunlight do you want to reflect and
different countries will have a
different idea about where that dial
should be set
a country like russia for example may
well want there to be a bit of warming
because it would mean
that they have a lot more arable land
and suddenly lots of siberia opens up to
being inhabited
whereas countries like for example um
egypt or places in the middle east
um may well want the temperature to be a
little lower than it actually was before
we started interfering with the climate
and there's going to be an international
tension about where that one dial
should be set i don't know if that's why
they did it like this in this movie or
possibly if it was just because they
wanted lots of satellites
but the international unity that would
be required to make a project like that
work
we've never seen it i'm not going to say
it's impossible but
we've never seen it and what happens if
one nation decides actually no this
isn't going very well we want to change
our minds
they found a way to neutralize the
storms with a net of thousands of
satellites
each deploying countermeasures designed
to impact the basic elements of weather
heat pressure and water
all over seen by the international space
station
what why why would it be the
international space station
it's it's a football pitch in space they
do like microgravity experiments not
weather manipulation how many extra
modules did you add
they gave the satellite net a technique
what but we all came to call it dutch
boy
after the story of the child who got the
damn with his finger
okay apparently they're reigning xanax
on the planet
what incarnation is that density of
satellites
that's a castle syndrome waiting to
happen kester syndrome is basically what
was depicted in the movie gravity
where um if you can get one satellite
colliding with another and producing
uh lots of fragments you can get a chain
reaction of all these satellites in
orbit
taking each other out much like a
nuclear chain reaction
um where you get more neutrons produced
for each fission but though that density
of satellites that is all but guaranteed
to happen that is
completely infeasible
what
oh wow that's a lot
this is what saved us all it was built
by a team
led by one man oh okay i have no doubt
that this movie is not going to go into
the details of the science but what they
appear to be doing there
is blowing up a hurricane they're
somehow
adding energy to it and causing
the colossal energy held within the
hurricane
to be dispersed
i mean yes technically a hurricane is
just an area of low pressure with a lot
of moisture around it
and so i suppose if you were to
artificially
raise the pressure of the eye of the
hurricane then it would stop rotating
but
you've then just superheated all that
water and it's gonna
it's not gonna look like that oh boy
this is so much this is so much worse
than i thought it would be actually
i had a low expectation as well i mean
the movie's got gerard butler in and
it's not 300.
the dutch boy guy right yeah man i need
to shake your hand oh
okay well it'd be nice if weatherman got
that kind of credit zap
blizzard zap
so the implementation of geoengineering
in this movie
is very much as we kind of already
talked about man versus nature
and um this idea that we are
fighting against the planet that you zap
a monsoon or a hurricane or whatever it
is now as a matter of fact there is a
whole chapter
about this kind of mindset uh when it
comes to geoengineering in
niamey cline where is it in naomi
klein's
excellent this changes everything um
about how basically geoengineering
is a classic example of a technological
fix to global warming
and it is a sticking plaster over
the problem without actually addressing
its root cause which is fundamentally
adding more carbon to the atmosphere
what it is and it's really it's like
this movie hits the nail on the head so
much
is this idea of technological supremacy
over nature nature being separate from
man
and man using a technological fix to
overcome
the way the damage we were doing it
means that oh yeah we can carry on our
behaviors previously
but yeah we've got a we've got a
sticking plaster we can actually just
don't worry about that aside from all
the other issues
with this way of thinking about things
um this basically
doesn't require any change to the root
cause of
the environmental damage that we're
doing it doesn't require us to change
our emissions
and this mindset is very much promoted
by the kind of people who would really
like to
be able to continue emitting as they are
so massive energy companies
um consumers with a high
carbon footprint lifestyle so basically
people in the west the idea of
geoengineering is particularly
intoxicating these people because it
means that we can continue emitting as
much carbon as
we want without suffering the negative
consequences
well well actually there would be a lot
of negative consequences
um a lot of people would probably die as
a result of geoengineering whilst the
overall
effect of solar radiation management
would be uh to
lower the average temperature of the
earth we are
pretty confident that in the aftermath
of
um major volcanic eruptions like mount
pinatubo in 1991
that a lot of people died from drought
and famine
in places like africa and those
historical events are the closest
precedent for the use of geoengineering
so
we actually can be pretty confident that
if we were to
deploy solar radiation management if we
were to manipulate the climate with this
technological fix
we would be saying yeah we're okay with
x number of people dying as a direct
result of our actions
rather than changing the fundamental
cause of the problem
which was the emission of gases of
greenhouse gases what this movie is
doing is basically papering over the
cracks
of uh the flaws in this mindset like the
movie's gonna go on to
to say you know you shouldn't play god
it's a natural system like roland's
connected probably
but it's not addressing that fundamental
problem
of uh you know oh yeah we can we can
just you know use our
fantastic technology we're the god
species we're on top of the earth we can
bend it to our will not have to change
our way of life
well it doesn't really work like that
failure to follow procedures numerous
violations of the chain of command
and then oh my god they're doubling down
on it
oh i i don't think i can watch the rest
of this
this is so doubling down on this idea of
the the uh the individual
the maverick individual the genius is
going to save everything which is just
like a subset of like
the very neoliberal way of looking at
the environment
and
okay so here's what i think we can draw
from this movie well the intro
because i basically can't get past that
one that the depiction of geo
engineering that it's depicting is
definitely not
in the scientific mainstream it's not
the solar radiation management idea of
injecting stuff into the stratosphere to
dim the sun basically two they have said
that this system has been implemented
in response to a sudden sharp change
in uh in anthropogenic climate change
basically there's this rise in extreme
events and that's simply not
in any way what we would expect to
happen and i think it's a very unhelpful
way of looking
at this issue that we expect it to
basically be doomsday
uh that's not what we expect and three
the way this movie is
framing geoengineering is very very
typical of the kind of people who
normally do talk about geoengineering
which is this idea of
humans mastery over the earth and
our ability using technology to fix a
problem and not actually address the
root cause the fact of the matter is
that geoengineering is a
highly controversial uh technology
but there is absolutely the capability
today to
use geoengineering not as depicted as
geostorm because
why you'd want to bombard the planet
with xanax i don't know but in a way
that would on average cool the planet
but we can also be very confident that
it would have
massive side effects and it would
particularly hit
a lot of communities that exist in the
global south that exist in the
developing world
that wouldn't realistically have a seat
at the negotiating table
that gets to decide you know how we do
this
massive climate experiment we could be
pretty sure that if we were to implement
it people
a lot of people would have their lives
irreversibly changed or just taken away
from them so i suppose that's something
this movie gets right is that you know
it's
this technology is dangerous but not not
quite as they are depicting it can we do
it yes
technically absolutely can the money is
available you know it probably wouldn't
be the united nations that would
actually do it it would probably just be
a wealthy individual
like bezos if you just got bored from
fighting ant-man but morally should we
do this
and also just in terms of you know
practically the other climate knock-on
effects and changes in precipitation and
plant growth and all these kind of
things
absolutely we shouldn't be doing it oh
there's so much we could talk about
during engineering maybe i don't know if
people like
this maybe i should do a follow-up video
this was basically just an experiment i
wanted to see how this
this style of doing a video would work
and also because i was kind of
morbidly curious about geostorm like i
say if you're interested in the broader
discussion of geo engineering i cannot
recommend this book enough i'm actually
i think it's the next video that's going
to come out this channel is going to be
a review of this and the other essential
reads that you should
have on your shelf about climate change
but if you'd like to see
a kind of a summary of a couple of the
details of the science and some stuff
that i didn't have time to fit in this
video
then i've written that up as a notion
page which will be linked down there in
the description in this i talk about the
different techniques of
geoengineering such as solar radiation
management some of the risks and
advantages of each one
and i hopefully make a case uh that is
compelling about why i don't
think we should do it for a lot of
reasons i've talked about notion in
previous videos about how i use it as
my management software basically my life
os for my youtube channel for my to-do
lists on a weekly basis for keeping
track of my goals and also things like
my address book and all that kind of
stuff
it's basically incredibly modular
software it's almost like a set of lego
bricks you can build however you want
and you'll see in the notion page links
in the description that there's so many
different ways you can put information
in there i've tried to
showcase a few different kinds and it
looks gorgeous it's an incredibly
easy way to put together information and
make it look good and make it all
interconnect with one another it's kind
of like building your own internet
almost like
when i my life os i can't imagine living
without it to be honest it's been
such a game changer now it used to be
the case that was five dollars a month
to get a personal notion account but
it's now
completely free so there is literally
nothing to lose by giving it a go
i cannot recommend it highly enough uh
if you'd like to get yourself a personal
account there's a link down there in the
description and on the screen
here oh that was good and um yeah i
can't recommend it highly enough
it's totally changed my productivity and
so many aspects of my life so check out
the page that i wrote about
geoengineering techniques
and also get yourself a free notion
account both links are down there thank
you for watching the video i realized
this was
like an unusual one but i i was morbidly
curious about how bad
geostorm was and also just to sort of
give this a go
um i'm a big fan of movies uh and i
would like to do more kind of videos
like this if you found it enjoyable if
you found it entertaining
um and hopefully informative so let me
know what you thought let me know if you
liked it or didn't like it in the
comments
and uh what you'd like me to look at
next maybe in this kind of format if you
enjoyed it do pop it a like and you can
even share it if you want that'd be nice
thank you very much for watching as i
say the next video is going to be about
reading recommendations for climate so
look forward to that and i'll see you
there
[Music]